hallo leute und willkommen zu blocken
estag nummer 10 und ich möchte euch ganz
herzlich begrüßen zu diesem
wunderschönen montag date bei euch
wahrscheinlich ein dienstag ist ich habe
heute fabelhafte pläne und ich freue
mich schon seit tagen darauf denn ich
fahre jetzt julians atelier und wir
werden zusammen ein bisschen kreativ
sein und ein bisschen malen und ich freu
mich einfach darauf ich weiß nicht warum
aber ich hab so lange wieder nicht
gemalt und ich hoffe einfach dass wir
was cooles machen und jetzt werde ich
sie gleich treffen und dann gehen wir
los
[Musik]
also wir sind jetzt ganz entspannt
das ist nicht schön ist das ist nicht
juli stellen mix von sebastian
aber das ist nur drei ist gut nur
dreimal 0 ist gut
absolut ach das sind so jacques i
versteh ich nicht bestimmt was man dort
ja soll wieder spaß heute doch mal in
die erste partie jetzt wieder verdeckt
ja kein adventskalender hier in köln
aber die hat ein von second wave oder ja
alle haben einen von segways ganz
ehrlich als ich gesehen habe wie alle
second wave leute diese ab wirklich oder
schreibt vielleicht also vielleicht weil
segway über die weihnachtszeit jeden tag
ein geschenk auspacken und ich habe alle
geschenke aus
ok tag nummer drei in weihnachtszeit
verfassen ich habe jetzt schon kommentar
gelesen ist jetzt mal genug influence
singen hier so weil ich irgendwie aber
leute in köln sind 100 youtuber was soll
ich denn hier filmen
so
die drei ja ich stand ja jetzt ist sowie
xbox fans papier wird auch dass länder
hat einen schuh und das ist echt cool
die kunst ist zeit das war mein zweites
video auf youtube die künstliche zeichen
ganz schlecht erinnern sich die leute
das universum das auspacken wenn wir
wissen wie ihr vorhaben das zu malen
du sagst noch sogar cool wenn der arzt
sind während wie cool oder
das ist mir ganz wichtig liebe so was
wenn man so nicht weitermachen soll dann
schlägt man es einfach auf und dann wagt
man okay jetzt mache ich das einfach ist
ja mal was ich denke ich nach ich mag es
einfach wie geil es würde ich auch ich
würde fast schenken aber ich werde mich
aber weiter das universum schicken in
letzter zeit echt immer so sachen weil
ich habe auch ein türchen nummer vier
war hab ich timo universum höher auf ihr
hab ich einen wunderbaren 1 gemacht dass
er mit ihm rein gemacht wurden dabei in
der regel also die wie kann das sein von
allen dingen die es gibt auf der ganzen
welt auf ihren gleichen türchen das
gleiche reingemacht von allen sachen die
es gibt auf der welt ja und wir haben ja
viele verschiedene sachen gemacht also
so aber darin wir beide auch nur einen
wunderbaren türchen nummer fünf
[Musik]
wenn du da so eine zitrone honig tee
trinkt ja ich liebe winnie puuh woher
weiß ist dass das reicht jetzt von dein
zimmer gegangen
eine wohnung die puste ist falsch die
ist richtig cool macht das trotzdem ein
geschenk
das ist die neuen das ist gut das sah
der tannenbaum raus und dann hatten wir
aber halten
einfach nur 8
der klausel gibt man sich obendrein
kommt vielleicht und ich ziehe dabei
machen die sie das so vorne an
das immer so anderes vorhaben die
leistungen wie so eine mail office sind
durch die wohnung
aber die putts auch immer gleich den
staub berger wenn ihr praktische sachen
ich dachte das wird nur swingin centers
aber eigentlich macht doch keinen sinn
soll
warum jetzt hier noch richtig gedanken
gemacht wie ich hätte das niemals nicht
gut für mich so dafür weiß ich nicht wie
viel 20 personen oder so wie lange
müssen sie daran gesehen und das alles
auch 1 ich kenne die geschichte
und so lag die ganze 12 ich habe
letztens eine dunkle wir sind nicht mit
hoch oder sind beitrag von lübeck und
seine musiker also schon das interessant
also ganz ehrlich so random fakes aber
so massiv ist auch ganz gut aber nie das
bestimmt aber vielleicht ist es auch
einfach geil sagt karsten heine
aha das ist für sich die hätte
eigentlich einmal so ein kreativ ist
gehen sollte nicht im ernst du brauchst
du regalen zu einem künstlern hier
betreten liebste bank wie hast du dieses
exit through the gift shop die 96
okay aber ich habe den bock brach aber
dann hast du immer größere dieses kühler
da gibt es kein schiffsanleger
superbörse aber der großteil richtig
gute geschenk angeboten um die berufs
management aus hit me up moore
vielleicht gut wir bauen jetzt aufnehmen
und dann erst mal was zu essen ok meine
natürlich noch weit von diesen
polnischen meister ja eine bombe hat die
luft ist raus gebracht und sie sind wenn
leute das machen und dann sagen die
einfach nur da ist geil hast doch so
eine subjektive bewertungen sagt doch
danach schmeckt also vom und gefürchtete
so an wie diese verpackungen zu
materialien so man hatte das gefühl da
rein zu beißen oder diese meist dinge
und so basteln kann kennst du ja man die
ist und dann nötig ist einfach so auf im
mund hat vielleicht die meist geschmack
auch wissen auch wie papier also ein
bisschen salzig
also ich möchte nicht so ähnlich wie die
pom bär
es war bestimmt vorher gar nicht wenn es
beim schnitt wer dich lieben aber sie
schmecken nicht nur pur bären stimmt das
kann man sagen
dann habe ich hier noch farben geholt
hat tatsächlich 150 euro dafür
ausgegeben
ja dieser finden
dabei wird auch die kunst und gut
behandelt
[Musik]
einmal derart youtube bleibt ja gar
nicht funktionieren will fischer kommt
ihr anderes bild als es verfügt wenn du
so weit dass ein paar seiten 8 gehäuse
leute erwarteten schön montag locken es
kommt dann morgen wieder ich habe
ordentlich was geblockt bzw
läuft da gerade meinen blog also da und
heute war es einfach ein streaming
versucht das so tipps hast wie es besser
geht schreibt sie mir gerne nach dieser
scheiße
[Musik]
das ist eine feine pixeln hat kleid
finally have to your land bat dies
fordert zugleich ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr glaubt was
es ist es ist ein fisch es ist eine
möhre
was denkt ihr was man sich das ist
einfach für die interpretation offen
und jetzt bin ich hier bei und kelly hat
sogar für mich gekocht dies wirklich die
kann mittlerweile so gut kochen schaut
mal und ich habe sogar gesagt kann es
auch ein bisher machen und dann hat sie
noch das gemacht und das ich bin so
stolz auf dich o
[Musik]
die new york mit das sehr lecker und ich
hoffe ihr hattet spaß batman uns nochmal
also wir gucken jetzt harry potter ich
habe gehört am 16.12 mit
das ist die musik studiert was hast du
heute alles nicht so viel ich habe
gefilmt wie ich weiß wirklich gemein
die stadt weist block bis machen wollte
eine stunde haben es ausprobiert eine
stunde saßen wir davon
dann haben wir es aufhört ich dachte so
wenn kelly ihr ziel gewesen wäre wir
werden in irgendein büro gefahren
hätten diesen live streams über leichen
gegangen von diesen live stream leute
das ist nicht mal gelogen
aber dann habe ich noch ein bisschen auf
instagram war ich live und tatsächlich
ist ein blog tag snape und die mutter
von drake machen gerade den
ungebrochenen packt den
das war ein unvergesslicher schuhe
probieren auch im pop ist für euch jetzt
noch ein bisschen da hast du schon
geschlafen bei den teil
du bist du du du hast wir haben den
angefangen zu gucken und nicht so sehr
geprägt und ich war ja ja genau weißt du
christ ich so auf die arbeiter dann
weißt du genau das so schlafen
dann bist du auf gestanden also wann
bist so rüber ins bett
das ist manchmal so ganz also wieso
haben sie eine komische beziehung
geschlafen nicht immer beieinander
ich habe noch ein mega flasche kennst du
annabelle die kuh die ein reh sein
wollte
also passt auf kelly kelly liest jetzt
von weihnachts 5
[Gelächter]
wunder einer winternacht hast du viel
beck schon gesehen um mein gott ich habe
beim podcast picasso vorhaben über
feedback gesprochen nicht so king
versuche ich mal rockig mal habe die
erste folge schaut leute schaut euch
liebe kann es ist die best geschriebene
serie die ich jemals gesehen habe macht
jetzt an wenn du willst sie ist einfach
hammer ich war so traurig dass es so
schnell vorbei war
hey hast du die ganze sehr frisch
angekommen sagte die erste folge durch
gesucht es ist so gut wie kann die hat
wir waren noch zeiten vorlocken willst
was ja als ich noch zeit hatte gut wir
schauen jetzt erwarte ich muss mir noch
was durchlesen überwiesen
[Musik]